i was not very good at school i failed  pretty much in school you know i did my  left school  instead of getting a normal job or still  going to university i made a million  pounds guess what i did after i made a  million pounds after i made a million  pounds i made another million pounds  then i made another million pounds then  i made another million pounds but you  know what's more important to me than  that  you know what's more important to me  than all those that i've made  i made another million then another  million now my net worth is 20 million  pounds and uh you don't have to be good  in school to make millions of pounds you  just need to be smart in business and  you need to work bloody yard